the cave lionesses on the hunt and their
wounded prey it's a world for more than
thirty thousand years ago with
rhinoceros bison wild horses captured on
the walls of the Chauvet Cave access to
the cave and the South of France is
restricted to researchers but now the
paintings have been faithfully
reproduced in an artificial cave that
will be accessible to all
see way up it's incredible how realistic
it all looks like in a real carrier you
can dive into the past and understand a
bit about how people lived back then off
isn't it
Anakin Kimo it's even humid like in a
real cave the artificial cave cost 55
million euros to construct it's all
meant to be as accurate as possible even
the smell right from the start the
planning at the active participation of
experts familiar with the real game such
as archaeologist vana beam or less it's
the largest reproduction ever and
everything you can see here the
paintings the bones have all been copied
exactly so in a way we're here in the
original cave the name is different
however it's called the cavern of pond
dog named after a bridge in the region
it's just two kilometers from the
original Chauvet Cave in the
southeastern ardèche state bottom all
the cave was discovered in 1994 by a
group of three hikers and named after
the leader of the group jean-marie
Chauvet the entrance had been blocked
off for some 20,000 years by fallen
rocks that helped preserve the more than
450 paintings of animals inside
considered some of the oldest works of
art in the world the find was a
sensation for scientists to protect the
precious paintings the cave was
immediately closed to the public
Fionnuala what today we know that having
lots of visitors alters the climate in
the cave it promotes the growth of
calcite sand mold and they destroy the
paintings to join in so the challenge
was to allow people to experience this
treasure of human history
in 2010 German director vana at salt
became the first filmmaker to be given
permission to film in the cave but under
strict guidelines a small team for a
brief time could ever take one like this
so it's five past three years at Sojat
his documentary in 3d to make the
spectacular cave paintings more vivid it
was a first attempt to make the Chauvet
Cave accessible to non-scientists the
second attempt was the new replica of
the cave digital measurements were made
of the original and transferred layer by
layer to a round structure at three
thousand square metres the replica is
less than half the size of the Chauvet
Cave but it contains all the important
paintings the present-day artists used
the same techniques as their prehistoric
predecessors Flintstone charcoal and
engravings for Michelle claim all who
oversaw construction it was the biggest
challenge of his life Mohicans uh we
basically had our doubts the whole time
like when we put the first sculptures in
the hall and they seemed so lost in this
big building only when the cavern
replica took shape did we start to feel
that we would manage it that it would
work oh my god be on the ivy
they did manage it a few visitors have
been able to have a first look including
a couple who run an inn not far from the
site I think it will be a good
alternative for tourists the ardèche is
mostly known for canoeing and now
there's finally a cultural highlight
that's very significant the cavern of
pond art will open on Friday for just 13
euros per person everyone can now
journey back to the Stone Age